hello everybody my name is Markiplier
and welcome to Five Nights with Freddy's
special delivery this game is different
than the other ones that you have seen
where the other ones have been computer
games this one takes it to another level
the animatronics have found their way
into your own home and through the power
of augmented reality
you can see where they are
now augmented reality is different the
virtual reality because what it means is
when I look through my mobile device
I can see the animatronics as they're
stalking me in my own room hey it might
work also it might not work I might lose
everything this is all new technology I
including how I'm recording this so I
may not be able to hear the animatronics
coming because I got airpods in no way
it's your lucky day we've sent our
highest rated animatronic as a preview
of our Sensational service Freddy
Fazbear is on his way hey that's really
cool good Wait no that's not cool that's
the opposite of cool that's literally
the worst thing that could possibly
happen all right let's go for it
Freddie's here he's just dying to see
you how good oh my god there it is
to show up
it appears our patented anim stealth
module is overreacting
what look around for residual
interference what
it seems Freddy's being a bit shy isn't
that cute ah just freaking adorable you
know how I love it use the flashlight to
help locate him okay
oh
oh wait
here
like what here
here wait no
yeah there
what just happened
oh dear Freddy sure isn't himself today
hi why
wait for Freddy to de-cloak then use
your shocker to reset him oh yeah
why is this my job
hello oh my God
that sure was fun
depends on who you ask Freddie depends
on who you ask congratulations you've
been selected for our newest service
you'll never know who's coming to visit
that's good oh that's a good thing right
that's oh just
oh
wait a minute
hang on there tick okay press yes now to
experience the best we have to offer for
the next 24 hours
you know
I'm okay you know there's something
something tells me that yeah I'm good
we're thrilled that you chose our
service we may now look forward
all right good oh God 909 I was hoping I
was Wishing Upon a Star I was praying to
the ye gods hopefully more years of
excitement I love excitement power
Eternal package another delivery is on
its way okay all right good I was hoping
for that too also as well fighting for
you you'll never be alone again great
even better it's what I was always
hoping for oh God damn it oh
hi hello
sure it's dark in this brightly lit room
of mine
okay
oh oh
okay
hello
am I doing this right
I don't know if I'm doing this right
wait wait wait wait wait wait wait oh
wait a minute you're in my wall
why are you in my wall
wait wait wait
oh did I mess up there or did uh what
I don't understand anything that's
happening here
I don't know what's going on oh God ah
there we go oh hey how you doing oh hey
how you doing Fred okay
foreign
I won and I got a robot
oh and lug nuts sure do love nuts system
override reboot the workshop will let
you modify your new endoskeleton how fun
is that so fun we don't have the same
definition of fun and bear and dough out
to collect Parts select deploy and then
select Salvage no send to a friend what
if I don't have any friends I don't have
friends
okay I don't have friends
I need to get myself some friends I
don't have any friends okay recall while
you're waiting for more fun to arrive
why not try out Remnant collection well
I didn't actually send anybody out so I
wait I all right sure one of remnants
look for bright Remnant around you use
the flashlight to draw it in and collect
it be careful to avoid the shadowy
remnant guarding it or you may get a
surprise you won't like it all what
what shot are we running
what are you talking about I'm sorry
what where is this oh oh that's not good
is this what I'm is this one got it oh
why are you closing in around me
oh okay this is this is one of those bad
things
this is one of those bad oh it's bad
where is it oh did I see it
wait a minute oh that's that's what I
want that's good
okay oh I'm not supposed to get the the
the the shadow ah I'm an idiot I was
collecting the dark stuff as if it was
good oh
all right take those please quiet
oh that's not good
Oh that's oh that's the opposite of good
oh this is one of those not good things
oh hi um
give me your give me your shadows
all right got that guy
well he sucks where
oh hi zero problems
[Music]
[Applause]
what can I say
have a nice day okay all right I got
Remnant I don't know congratulations on
completing your expert user
certification you now have the tools to
enjoy an eternity of Friendship with the
Fazbear family okay good what's coming
towards me I'm gonna deploy you go stop
go get out and go go oh wait wait wait
wait wait wait wait wait wait what
wait wait wait a minute wait wait a
minute oh I hear you
oh
where are you
you're over there by my computer it's
like an infinite display
of animatronic health
hello oh
hello oh yeah
all right if only I actually got Freddy
oh
my God I'm the best that ever existed I
am what
why am I why am I remnanting I didn't
ask for remnants
I didn't
I neither wanted this nor ordered it
just like most of these animatronics
they seem to be paying me
a lot of attention lately anybody else
hearing some weird whispering
the whole augmented reality thing is
kind of way I'll take dog yeah
the whole augmented reality thing is
just kind of weird
but in a cool way like it's it's a new
it's it's a very different way of
playing games than I'm used to
okay that's not good
I still don't know why I'm collecting
The Remnant a lot of things happen when
delivery started being made to the wrong
address here oh that's not right
oh god oh my god oh no
okay
easy
easy peace
okay oh wait no there's one more I'm
sorry I thought that was that
where where where
oh God
that's bizarre that's really bizarre oh
you're not dead how are you not dead oh
God
all right well
foreign
[Applause]
for nothing Baby Please be aware of your
surroundings at all times while playing
yeah isn't that the point of the game
oh God all right someone's at my door I
guess is this a different one yeah
there'll be no quarter for you right
sorry foxy
oh
burden
burden
pardon oh
what the hell is that
wow okay okay that was that I don't know
if I did that right
oh my God
I did it
good why I've got so much mail oh my god
I've got so much mail ah
head to the workshop and fill them up
all right I'll fill you up with Remnant
you want some remnant get it
[Music]
did I fill you up what happened
I feel like there should have been a bit
more Pizzazz for that but apparently
apparently not okay
um all right
oh man I'm just gonna get some
I don't know where it is okay those are
just Shadows oh
please thank you I don't know if it
helps if I actually move through my
environment
oh
get that thank you
thank you thank you you guys want a good
drink
you guys wanna
you wanna drink here hey it's like it's
like a heist with markiplier oh wait
I'm so thirsty you know like I need this
refreshing delicious drink here
close that up
oh is that a Remnant oh wait no it's not
it's a whole lot of hold on nothing
oh time to crack open
it
Murphy and speaking of slurping come at
me buddy Boop you're gonna get a I'm
gonna get a whole lot of delicious
you don't mind if I do
oh no I need my drink
I've made some errors oh hi
we got a lot of Shadows around my
eyeballs
whoa whoa we're losing it we're losing
it you you you you you you you hey hey
[Music]
ah
old
oh man
I don't know what the hell happened why
did my screen go one kazoozle ah
disruption we've been seeing an
increased amount of reports regarding
customers oh God rare malfunction hand
sanit interference becomes increasingly
obscured shaking the device oh Shake I
gotta shake it of course that makes
sense wait a minute
way a hot second here
whoa oh
you're in my light
you're somewhere in my life okay
all right
okay
all right
okay
oh God
I shocked you
all right shocked him oh am I running
why are they taking all my Remnant
they're after me lucky Remnant
animatronics behaves erratically
including severe erratic movements
including head spinning immediately
looking away from the animatronic what
huh but I thought I had to shock them
looking away from me hey what does that
even mean what do you mean I don't know
what that means I need more Remnant oh
there's something here
okay I don't need that it's nothing but
shadows and shapes I'm not seeing
nothing oh finally one glorious Remnant
thank you thank you for that
thank you I got one
one oh who two
oh yes please I don't even need oh
that's not good oh wait a minute that's
where are they boxing me in oh God oh
God oh God
okay that's fine
oh what wait what
we take away they can just pop in when
I'm in the middle of something
where are you
what was that
what was that oh right there
I've got you where are you come on what
are you gonna do what are you gonna do
huh what are you gonna do
I I know you're there
I literally know you're there wait
where'd you go there
something just I feel like that's why
did I just wear it what did I just see
ah
oh God I'm not supposed to look at you I
did
I did no my Remy's calling come back
home come home to me baby come home to
me bearendo okay whatever I guess I just
gotta
like I said I just got to keep going for
Remy's some sweet delicious remingtons
I'm Gonna Get You Remy's whoa is that a
Remy out here
I wouldn't mind if you run oh don't mind
if I do thank you okay it's nothing but
[ __ ] oh God okay oh no balloony boy hey
come on now
who's been a silly silly
oh
hi oh shake shake okay easy easy easy
yeah I easy I got you oh wait a minute
[Music]
ain't no way
got him
it's okay okay all right okay let's tap
out for a bit tapping for just a bit
okay
so that is Five Nights at Freddy's
special
delivery it's the kind of game Sorry and
then Shadow right now it's the kind of
game
that
you really gotta play
to really appreciate that's really cool
it's a very interesting implementation
of Technology
I didn't expect it to be that cool I
really didn't I didn't know I've never
played an AR game before in my life but
I can definitely see how you could get a
lot of enjoyment out of it if you've got
a lot of people on your friends list
then you could probably send
animatronics to go hunt their dreams and
that sounds pretty cool I don't have any
friends but maybe for the next episode
if I do this again
I'm gonna get some friends so thank you
everybody so much for watching if you
want to play this for yourself I will
provide a link right there in the
description if you've got friends Santa
animatronics their way and let me know
how that goes for you thanks again and
as always I will see you in the next
video
bye-bye
[Music]